i watched the first season of the tv
series i got like two episodes into the
second tv series where they were
repeating everything yeah
and i was just like no okay i would say
that i worry he
still is very much worth watching in
this day and age because of
disappearance disappearance is still
my it's probably my favorite
anime franchise film of all time i agree
and up
up there is one of my favorite anime
films of all time and this this guy
apparently [ __ ] hates it so
i i think the the whole series is kind
of mediocre i don't know wow really
i the first season was just fine right i
was watching it and i was like
okay i know this is a terrible
comparison but i was just like man this
just feels like
toradora but like worse i don't know why
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
there's zero romance in there no
no because the whole setting reminded me
so much of like
toradora and the way that it was sounded
like it was set in a school
like every anime i know this is like a
complete
stupid opinion on my part i recognize
this is a garbage opinion
but the whole time i was just like i
guess because it was just
okay i was very bored a lot of the time
watching how the only thing that made me
want to watch it
was uh the fact that uh crispin freeman
voiced kyon no that's not
the best part because yeah he was
amazing i know he was a treat watching
him yeah well you said he's like saying
oh yeah anohana was kind of like another
because they have ghosts in it or
whatever
you know that's a fair comparison god
i mean i don't know because like okay
what should they both start with a in
what show can you compare harry susamia
to if you had the closest comparison
here's the thing like how he susan mia
inspired
a lot of like i came after that that
huge way i became an anime fan after
that huge thing that had its impact
right
so i think i came into it with like zero
attachment to it in any sense yeah
because i think the thing with
hierarchy that i find really interesting
is the fact that it's one of those anime
that is like
really weirdly tied to the period that
it came out in much like lucky star
i feel because like i think that's why i
don't give a [ __ ] about it right because
like
the thing the thing is like i [ __ ]
love both lucky stuff
especially lucky stuff like i think it
feels [ __ ] amazing but like
the problem is that the references in
lucky star and like the whole
fact that it really reflected the ortaku
culture of
the 2000s is what made that show really
funny
in the mid 2000s but as much as i love
lucky star
i can't really recommend it to people
today no because
the scene has just completely changed
yeah but does that mean you can
recommend haruhi suzumiya today
yes i can really yeah because i think i
ruined it for myself
yeah you i think you you basically just
watched the climax
you you watched the climax before like
watching any of the build-ups yeah
so now you just kind of that's why i
kind of don't feel bad for being like
yeah i think it's not that good
because i'm like i know i ruined it for
myself and it might have been the only
way to like top that experience is if
you committed to reading all of the
light novel
i'm not i'm i'll be dead forever
i'm never reading i did that and like
the final final volume of harahi was
like
pretty [ __ ] good so you just have to
sit
reading a light novel ever because i
remember like a lot of the elements in
harahi have been done in other places
now because like there's a lot of like
self-referential humor in harahi
and i remember when that was like an
innovative thing like i remember when
every [ __ ] light novel wasn't wasn't
trying to parody every [ __ ]
every other light novel yeah yeah and
now it's just it's just gotten so
[ __ ] lazy with its self-referential
hero well again like that's the whole
thing where it comes to like the time
period i sound like anime boomers
we had it better back then you should
have sure
in 06 when haruhi and lucky star came
out
like as you said like the whole like
self-referential thing and i think the
whole meta aspect
of anime was just so new like i remember
it was such a waste of modernism
it was so post modern at the time
because like i remember like
at the end of every lucky star episode
while the credits were rolling there was
no
ending song for lucky star what it was
was it was the scenes of
all of the lucky star characters in a
karaoke booth but you were outside of
the karaoke booth so you could only hear
them but
the conversations that they were having
in the karaoke booth weren't
characters having a conversation with
characters it was voice actresses having
a conversation with voice actresses yeah
and people like
of course they're voiced by voice
actresses these aren't just characters
on a screen they're real people
and that meta was like that was [ __ ]
cool because no other anime did that
you're laughing he is laughing you know
you're gonna stand
sit down you're gonna sit down and
you're gonna respect this culture
you're gonna respect this i just don't
care
it was cool back in the day yeah